à quoi ressemblera la voiture du futur
selon google a sera sans conducteur
comme ces voitures qui sillonnent déjà
les routes américaines depuis six ans à
pau travaille aussi sur son projet mais
c'est toyota maintenant qui attire
l'attention dans son mathieu sa cellule
le toyota qui veut se lancer dans une
aventure dans l'auto assister on veut
créer l'espèce de thau invincible qui
n'auraient jamais d'accident projet de
cinq ans 50 millions de dollars avec les
mighty steinfeld et tous ceux gérés par
un ex de la darpa donc le pentagone la
branche de recherche et de développement
j'ai le prat donc on vise très haut
l'originalité c'est que c'est une
voiture vous dites assisté avec
conducteur oui on veut garder le volant
une bonne vieille rincon bonne vieille
idée on veut garder le volant toyota
veut créer cette auto assisté là comme
un peu dans les avions de ligne où il ya
un ordinateur entre les commandes du
pilote est ce que l'avion faible on veut
faire la même chose avec le taux une
auto donc qu'ils veulent nous empêcher
de faire des manoeuvres hasardeuses une
toux qui va nous réveiller quand on
somnole une auto l'intelligence
artificielle vient en appui aux
conducteurs mais il ya un conducteur
savarin de l'ac arles et contre les
contre c'est que les ordinateurs
conduisent quand même mieux que nous en
tout temps malgré ce qu'on pense de
notre conduite par exemple regarder les
autos de google les autos autonome
depuis 2009 elles sont sur les routes
il y en a 25 et font 16 mille kilomètres
par semaine combien d'incidents depuis
2009 20 et ce sont des incidents qui
sont créés par les gens qui sont à
l'intérieur et qui se substitue à
l'ordinateur dans des situations de
danger
alors c'est dire que l'être humain est
moins bon que l'ordinateur en fait en
conduite des sautes d'humeur bon lait
pour les pauvres c'est que ici pas bien
d'un point de vue marketing toyota veut
garder l'aspect plaisir veut que les
gens aient l'impression d'avoir un
contrôle sur ce qui se passe exacte à
laquelle extérieur est aussi en cas de
danger en cas de défaillance du système
informatique mais on peut toujours
prendre le vol reprendre le volant alors
qu'une sécurité et ça pourrait peut être
aider les personnes âgées à convient
absolument les problèmes de piratage
parce qu'évidemment il ya des craintes
de ce côté là mais sont déjà présents
ses proches un problème de piratage on a
vu par exemple fiable tresses le
rappeler 1.5 million de véhicules parce
que des journaliste de wired ont réussi
à faire
infecter des autos avec des pirates
c'était l'été dernier on voit par
exemple le taux de google qui était
illuminé par des pirates le système
d'anti collision de l'auto autonome de
google ont été éliminés par des lasers
récemment par des pirates
les autos se sont immobilisées les
possibilités de piratage et sont énormes
dans les autos qui sont en vente
actuellement mais dans la za taux qui
vont être en vente dans quelques années
il faut pas l'oublier c'est un jeu et
celle de la souris et a contrario on
pourrait dire également qu'en 1973 et
2200 morts sur les routes du québec
il n'y avait pas grand ordinateur dans
les autos à ce moment là c'est vraiment
si on peut alors ces deux problèmes se
saouler avec ou de sa merci beaucoup
matière au plaisir c